[Music]
a world cup of triumphs
sets of excitement and heartbreak
this was definitely going to be always
Messi's World Cup
through it all Al Jazeera teams from all
over the world
they've been there to inform and
contextualize
Stadium
the fans here groups of fans together
that they will do whatever it is what
argentinians are feeling here in central
Buenos Aires happy Dutch fans here I can
tell you that and you've gone from
England to Wales this was not supposed
to happen
football fans from remote Pacific island
nations to Messi supporters in South
Asia thousands of people from India
altazira was the voice for Millions
connected by the beautiful sport
hundreds of Crews and teams have been
working around the clock to bring the
world's most unique football tournament
to a global audience
so hundreds of thousands of people
pouring onto the streets when the
Moroccan team returned back to the
country and people said thank you for
the joy you gave us
Croatia managed to do it once again
every time I see Ghana there's this
Pride that I get
I am Canada's World Cup Super Fan
when it comes to soccer because we're
really excited and we're thankful for
for any type of support we can get
[Applause]
fire a whole new generation of
footballers
the truth is that he deserves the best
in life because he's a beautiful person
a born leader and he will make all of us
happy we are already champions
foreign
[Applause]
look at that absolutely stunning
bringing you not just a sport
but also their footballs are made
the Jets and warships providing security
the story of the laborers and migrants
who made the infrastructure it's not
just about fans this cricket stadium is
filled with thousands of Migrant workers
to the thousands of men and women who
volunteered and those Who provided
security entertainment and hospitality
This World Cup has been full of
surprises
[Music]
q1
[Music]
the first World Cup in the Middle East
has been that of breaking records
including the one of the highest number
of viewers our mission to inform is
going to continue even after the
tournament from all our teams here in
Qatar and all over the world thank you
for watching